How long does the iron pro-wave last before needing to be replaced?
So the iron pro-wave is the foot bath apparatus for the true rife.
So you don't have a true rife ignore the answer to this.
I am pro-wave foot bath apparatus for the true rife lasts about 40 to 60 sessions before
it needs to be replaced, but it partly depends on how you use it.
So if you're using it a few times a week, three, four times a week, it's going to last 40
to 50 sessions, as long as you're cleaning it correctly according to your instructions
that came with your rife system.
If you don't clean it correctly, it's going to last a little less.
Now, honestly, we've had people that say, oh, wine's lasted 60 sessions and I've never
cleaned it once.
Partly depends on your water.
So remember, you're putting your tap water in the bucket and you're putting your unit
in there and you're adding salt.
So if you have high calcium in your water, if you have high iron content, all sorts of things
can change that.
I don't know how chlorine and fluoride act on the iron pro-wave unit either.
So I'm not sure Beth causes more detrimental effects.
Also if you only use it like once every three weeks, it's going to probably last less time
because you're using it less number of sessions, maybe more time, but it's going to last number
of sessions because you're using it and then it's because it does corrode unless you completely
took it apart and dried the whole thing after each one, which is nonsense.
Nobody's going to do that, but so it's going to corrode with the water sitting on it dry.
That's going to be a lot of the corrosion.
If you have issues with your iron pro-wave, you have to contact true rife because we don't
service those anymore and we don't even sell those anymore because we don't get any discount
on it.
It's just cheaper for you to buy it from true rife.
And then if you have issues, then they're going to be more apt to be able to replace it
because they have the final say in their product.
So contact true rife if you have issues with it, but most people don't have too many issues
with their iron pro-wave.